auch technologisch soll corona bekämpft
werden und zwar mit hilfe einer app die
nutzerinnen und nutzer warnt wenn sich
einer der kontakte im nachhinein als
infiziert herausstellt doch es gibt
streit um die technische ausrichtung
bedeutet das das aus der wahren app
bevor sie überhaupt an den start gehen
kann fix um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen und krieg zum
salz und wünschen gibt es jetzt auch als
podcast der link ist unten in der video
beschreibung unentschieden draufklicken
wenn ihr clixoom unterwegs hören wollt
also viele europäische
forschungseinrichtungen und firmen haben
sich zusammengeschlossen um die korona
pandemie auch technologisch zu bekämpfen
das projekt trägt den namen petty und
das steht für pan european privacy pries
irving proximity tracing tracing meint
dabei etwas anderes als tracking zwar
werden kontakt der verfolgt aber eben
nicht die orte an denen sie
stattgefunden haben das heißt also dass
das ganze ohne standortdaten
funktionieren soll auf grundlage dieses
software gerüst soll dann eine waren app
programmiert werden möglicherweise
unterschiedliche nationale oder sogar
auf mehrere apps in ein und demselben
land solch eine one app soll dann
infektionsketten nachverfolgen und alarm
geben sobald sich ein kontakt
nachträglich als infiziert herausstellt
spricht dabei werden auf dem eigenen
handy lediglich die dies der smartphones
gespeichert in deren ehemann sich sagen
wir meinen letzten zwei oder drei wochen
gefunden hat und auch auf den anderen
mobiltelefon wird meine idee gespeichert
sobald eine kontaktperson als auch ich
positiv getestet wird werden die anderen
gewand und sollen sich dann in
quarantäne begeben bei einer anderen
variante werden diese daten aber nicht
nur auf den handys gespeichert sondern
auch zentral infektionsherde sollen so
also in der zeit nach dem shutdown viel
schneller erkannt werden denn nur so
können infektionsketten rechtzeitig
unterbrochen werden und infizierte
identifiziert und isoliert werden eine
gute sache um die pandemie weiter in
schach zu halten selbst wenn es weniger
beschränkungen gibt laut plan auf der
liste ganz oben die privatsphäre der
nutzerinnen und nutzer denn die
anwendung sollten auf jeden fall mit den
eher strengen europäischen datenschutz
regeln vereinbar seinen bürgerinnen und
sollen übrigens freiwillig entscheiden
können ob sie die app nutzen oder eben
nicht die deutsche politik hatte sich
für diese basistechnologie das ppt
ausgesprochen und damit allen anderen
bereits existierenden apps aus singapur
südkorea oder österreich eine absage
erteilt anfangs war von einem konsortium
die rede dass aus 130 individuelle und
institutionen besteht doch mittlerweile
sind immer mehr hauptakteure bei diesem
geplanten europäischen vorzeige projekt
abgesprungen nicht mehr mit dabei sind
das helmholtz-institut für
informationssicherheit die katholische
universität leuven und die turiner
forschungsstiftung easy auf weitere
institutionen stehen mittlerweile nicht
mehr hinter dem projekt das
hauptsächlich von christian bos vom ki
unternehmen arango und thomas wiegand
vom heinrich hertz institut der
fraunhofer gesellschaft vorangetrieben
wird
es ist vor allem die technische
ausrichtung um die heftig debattiert
wird die große frage hierbei lautet soll
das konzept eben zentral oder dezentral
gefahren werden bei der zentralen
lösungen würden die anonymisierten und
über bluetooth ausgetauschten kennung
der einzelnen app userinnen und user auf
einem server gespeichert werden
betrieben werden könnte dieser vom staat
oder aber von einem daten treuhänder im
gegensatz zu dieser zentralen lösung
würden bei einem dezentralen konzept die
ids der smartphones der kontaktperson
dezentral zwischen den jeweiligen
geräten ausgetauscht und verwaltet
werden
das setzt also nicht so viel vertrauen
voraus wie das zentrale system denn die
meisten berechnungen werden direkt auf
den smartphones der userinnen und user
durchgeführt dem projektverantwortlichen
hans christian boos zufolge seit petit
offen für beide konzepte
doch auf der webseite des projektes
fehlten plötzlich die hinweise auf das
dezentrale protokoll
die bi suite und das ohne begründung
hans christian boos hatte außerdem in
einem interview gesagt dass er eine
deutsche app mit einem zentralen server
priorisiert bus ist übrigens auch
mitglied im digital rat der
bundesregierung die kritiker und
kritikerin waren davor dass dieses
modell anfällig für einen systematischen
missbrauch sei und zudem heimlich
ausgebaut werden könnte sprich wir geben
unsere daten erstmalig einem zentralen
server preis was passiert dann in
zukunft damit wie kann missbrauch
ausgeschlossen werden stattdessen
300 wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler in einem offenen brief
an alle länder dass der anspruch sein
sollte die privatsphäre durch das
jeweilige design zu garantieren und
nicht durch das pure vertrauen in die
betreiber in dem offenen brief heißt es
unter anderem dass eine solche tracing
app auf jeden fall freiwillig genutzt
werden sollte außerdem sollten die
systeme nach meinung der fachleute so
entwickelt werden dass sie abgeschaltet
und die daten gelöscht werden können
sobald die krise vorbei ist auch aus
deutschland haben 55 fachleute diesen
brief unterschrieben der sich zwischen
den zeilen wie eine kritik an dem
aktuellen kurs von patti lesen lässt
zudem weisen kritiker und kritikerinnen
darauf hin dass eine zentrale
speicherung der europäischen datenschutz
grund verordnung widerspricht ein
grundsatz der datenschutz grund
verordnung dsgv in artikel 5 absatz 1 c
ist das prinzip der datensparsamkeit und
daten minimiert
dieses prinzip würde bei einer zentralen
lösung missachtet andere fachleute geben
aber zu bedenken dass auch ein
dezentrales system schwächen aufweist
denn hier müssen alle geräte
untereinander kommunizieren das hat die
folge dass alle anderen geräte die id
desjenigen kennen der die warnung
verschickt hat derjenige also der ganz
sicher infiziert ist auch hier besteht
die gefahr dass eine datenlücke
entstehen könnte und das auch noch bei
besonders sensiblen gesundheitsdaten
andere experten experten sehen den
aktuellen streit nicht so eng so zum
beispiel der ki forscher paul lukowicz
in einem interview mit dem tagesspiegel
ob der zentrale oder dezentrale ansatz
gewählt wird ist nicht so wichtig das
ist eher ein philosophischer streit wie
die frage nach linux oder windows er
bezeichnete die debatte als
kontraproduktiv bleibt nur zu hoffen
dass man sich schnell einig wird und den
bestmöglichen datenschutz gewährleistet
zum einen damit die krone waren app
schnell an den start gehen kann und zum
anderen damit unser aller vertrauen in
sie nicht schon vor dem eigentlichen
start verloren geht was den erfolg der
app höchst fraglich macht denn
mindestens 60 prozent der bevölkerung
müssen sie nutzen damit sie die
infektionsketten effektiv stoppen kann
schlimmes datenleck bei facebook
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
zwar krieg zum science fiction falls das
noch nicht getan haben solltet bis dann
bleibt dran